3時するを買うときは青くになったじゃないですかアレような落ちた席でもう1回ハイ
ブリッジしたら髪の毛がまっすぐになってしまいました
和美社長です見ながら表現ショップ使いますでしょ
ちょっとした小物とか何かを変えたいとき一番手っ取り早いのは100円ショップだと
思うんですけどそんな100円ショップの中にもうものによっては全然100円に見え
ないものがたくさんある
と思うんですねこの高開ければ安っぽいへさぁ100円だなって思うんですけどもなん
かには100円に全く見えないものがあるねっ
それ100円と思うのは抵抗あると思うんですよそこで今回はダックスしてみたいこと
がありまして100円ショップで買ったものをあたかも
100円以上のものであるように見せてどこまでそのものの値段を上げられる
かというのはちょっとやってみたいと思いますこれなんか別に1回というの企画じゃ
ないんです今後もたがもう1回とかいろいろやってみると思うんですけど今から去り
ゲイナーずある人に100円で買ったものを紹介してメッチャメチャ盛りますめっちゃ
持ってボッタクリっ表良くないでスポットで超強力なんですけどめちゃくちゃ持って
当たっ100位ぞ
のもの
4に見せてそれで遠いとかそれで100円以上もなぁと思ったら僕の勝ちですっていう
のをちょっとやってみたいと思いますけど僕はユーチューバーな
てあのものを紹介するお仕事なわけですよ言い方を変えればなんで一家にその200円
だったものを100円以上にも見せるかって有能で歌めっちゃ9さんの思うんですよ
なんならぼったくりちゃんができると思いますそれぐらい多分そのものを紹介するスキ
ルっていうのは結構釣れている方だと思うんで100円のものを動向まで高く見せ
られるか清掃してみたいと思います受けて金
が紹介するのはこちら簡単ミップシーラー
お菓子のフクロウとかこれあればもう1回防ぐみたいなません
これは凄いですよなかなか100円には見えませんからね
てこれが100一定もすごい良いもうこれで中2できるのかナポレオンカード入れる
スリーブがありますこれもアーク状態なんですけどこれで止めてるん
おおおおっ赤ダメだったたピアはまず
会やまあこれ貼って中ですごいてしかもなので競って畳んでくれます
[音楽]
あったんで王様もやばいやばいやばい
見てっ
大府ゲー
まあすごいつ丁寧で今からこれを果たし何円までもれるのか
僕のぼったくり商法の力を利用して人にこれを紹介して値段がないんであるか聞いて
みようと思います職員が声では俺の勝ち
何
その他カッターんポテチとか食ったらさあ残したりするだために
あれて年かそのはチップ4日3色るじゃん
そういう時どうすって言う
自分9いきます
苦しい旅館残さないですねうん
ノッサ得意な彼らの個性しというじゃないからねっ
これ
なった
何でも飛び出るみたいです
スゴっているんですよ皆すごいのなんかねつか分からないん
甘くあぶですねうん余ってないそう思ってくるそうなってならちょうど空いてること
違いの頃はすごいん
近いった時間超大丈夫違うんですよね
はいたまーすイェーイずっと中のクローゼットの中にほい入ってあったがずっと多分1
ヶ月2ヶ月ございますね
ちょっとして言ってる可能だよやばけれども
細いパンチの黒グラ your ある者例えばね
2日分はい
グループ
けれど
木組みデー
くっついてるそうなんですっ
これもんだ何かがデリック暑い暑い暑いのは暑いです
藤堂にとっていうかも下落いらっしゃるかもしれないじゃんああすごいこれすごいね
どこだっていいんだぞ
あけおめいんぬんですよね
ポローン
4すごい大丈夫かねっ裏振らないと切れないですよね
先生これなんか今まではな開発途中で
守破離を入れては屋さんで行くなどもだとすごく企業参加6
そううんはい何でもくっつくん
プレイですよ帰りましたーっ今日
ザッパでこーいちさん怖い戦知事知事てありませんでした
なぜならその感じだなぁ
まあ
枚しないじゃなくてこんな大すっっ
か本当にすごい種たんだこれないんだと思う
これでしょいや
一番合成割ってみたのですもーっ
[音楽]
me
car
me あった
山100円でしたよっすぃ今ですが覚えたから降り学園ってですこそ
100円だったか今総格だったから犬じゃないません
[音楽]
謁見のものを
ないまでぼったくってみてみるか選手権ですかね
ぐっちゃ